scusate per l'attesa la vita e su una
tombola de noche de dia lo si potrebbe
dire con le parole di manu chao che dice
che la vita una tombola di notte e di
giorno oppure si potrebbe pensare quando
forrest gump si dice candidamente la
vita è come una scatola di cioccolatini
non sai mai quello che ti capita
ecco dentro queste due citazioni quello
che ci trovo io che mi appartiene e che
penso che appartenga a tutti noi
e dunque imprevedibilità della vita
il fatto che ci possa sempre essere
qualcosa che non ci aspettavamo che non
avevamo previsto e vi sarete chiesti
perché questa ragazza entra con queste
tre palline
io non sono una si scelse anche se in
realtà non mi dispiacerebbe ma quello
che per me rappresentano queste tre
palline un po metaforicamente è il
circolo della vita e quindi sapete è
facile farne girare due lo farebbe anche
un bambino
e chissà quante volte verranno fatte
girare anche a voi però è proprio
secondo me è proprio la terza che rende
le cose più difficili e dunque più
interessanti ecco quello che è successo
a me all'età di 18 anni è stato un
qualcosa di imprevisto una variabile
hicks che non mi aspettavo
ecco io stavo tranquillamente vivendo la
mia vita quando all'improvviso la mia
terza pallina è caduta che cosa è
successo
stavo tornando da una festa allegra
felice e spensierata di notte e con
pirata della strada ha deciso proprio
quella sera proprio in quel momento di
portarmi via metà della mia gamba
sinistra
e con questo si è portato via le mie
speranze di futura pallavolista sempre
dato via la spensieratezza di quegli
anni di uscire con le amiche a far festa
sui tacchi alti senza senza pensare
troppo a che cosa significhi fare le
scale a che cosa significhi avere due
gambe inter e io fino a quel momento non
sapevo che cosa significasse la fortuna
di avere due gambe la fortuna di avere
la salute e provate a immaginarvi quanto
si possa essere stata dura ritrovarsi
essere disabile a 18 anni a dover
prendere il cartellino per la macchina
perché sei disabile e ti spetta però è
una cosa che al cuore fa male
immaginatevi essere in ospedale e e non
riuscire a muoversi a lavarsi da soli
ricordo quello è stato proprio il fondo
per me e da quel fondo quando ero lì ho
pensato dentro di me verranno verranno
momenti migliori e dunque la vita era lì
ad aspettarmi la posta in gioco era
troppo alta troppo 18 anni cioè tu devi
esplodere non puoi stare a piangere sul
divano e quindi quello che
e quindi quindi quello che potevo fare
era solo spiegarmi raccogliere la terza
pallina e ricominciare a vivere in un
modo un po diverso grazie troppo gentili
in un modo un po diverso nel senso che
le cose erano cambiate adesso non avevo
più mezza gamba ma in realtà avevo tutto
tranne mezza gamba
quindi mi sono messa alla mia protesi e
ho ricominciato a fare tutto andare a
ballare in discoteca girare le città
fare forse anche di più di quello che
facevo prima
perché era come se si fossero abbattute
certe barriere certi freni inibitori che
che ti fanno sentire male o a disagio io
ero fatto così dopo un po pensato o mi
prendete così per come sono
oppure non mi prendete ma io continuo a
correre lo stesso e a proposito della
corsa
una volta raggiunta la normalità che
tanto sognavo in quegli anni perché mi
son sentita diversa ed è brutto sentirsi
diversi sentire che quando entra in un
locale hai tutti gli occhi addosso e ti
fanno male e non pensi che magari ti
stiano guardando perché sei carina ma
pensi che stanno guardando solo la tua
disabilità e non te come persona e
quello che è arrivato dopo un paio
d'anni dall'incidente e che ha
completato
diciamola la mia risalita verso verso il
milione
la mia risalita verso la normalità e la
felicità in sostanza è stata è stato il
ritorno della mia passione e cioè lo
sport ecco io prima facevo pallavolo e
poi ho deciso che volevo tornare a
correre avevo perso troppi pullman per 5
metri
perché non riuscivo a correre ecco non
solo per questo ho voluto tornare a
correre ea provare a vedere che cosa si
provasse ancora con una protesi
non è stato facile perché le sensazioni
sono molto diverse
devi abituare
il tuo fisico c'è il tuo schema motorio
è un altro però ce l'ho fatta mi è
piaciuto e da quel momento lì non ha più
smesso
e grazie allo sport e ho potuto
conoscere davvero che cos'è la
disabilità davvero come vissuta in tutto
il mondo perché cominciando a viaggiare
ho conosciuto atleti di tutto il mondo
australia cina ma anche semplicemente in
europa germania francia e parlando con
loro e vedendo come loro si
approcciavano la disabilità o davvero
radicato in me il pensiero che un
disabile è prima di tutto una persona
con sentimenti passioni desideri una
persona come tutti gli altri e se
vogliamo vedere anche un valore aggiunto
che il fatto che ogni mattina al
disabile si sveglia e deve far fronte a
un piccolo problema o grande che sia
e già il fatto che lo riesca a superare
questo quasi con questo fattore secondo
me gli conferisce più energia più forza
e in questa mia avventura
ecco una cosa che davvero non mi sarei
mai aspettata era è proprio quella di
arrivare fino
se l'aspettava da letto di ospedale di
arrivare in uno stadio con 80mila
spettatori e poi da lì ho iniziato non
ho più smesso scusate mi sono dedicata a
provare tutti gli sport
qui abbiamo sono io ve lo giuro è in uno
sport che sia mai sledge hockey
fantastico faticosissimo che lo che
equivalente se dovuti praticamente e poi
qui ho incontrato un ragazzo non so se
l'avete mai visto un certo bolt era uno
dei miei sogni comunque incontrare il
campione qua uno dei tanti primi che mi
hanno dato dopo la vittoria a londra
qui in una mia esperienza televisiva con
una tv online e qualche modo medaglie
perché ormai è diventata una cosa che
chi mi diverte e assai e poi il parà
snowboard anche quello bellissimo e poi
ho scalato le torri del vajolet
quest'estate anche lì non mi sarei mai
aspettata di arrivare fino al cucuzzolo
e via dicendo
e questa è l'ultima ultima esperienza
che ho fatto a soci alle paralimpiadi
dove sono andata come inviato al
giornalista e come vedete ogni scusa era
buona per fare foto con gli atleti e
dopo tutte queste esperienze ecco quello
che mi sento di dirvi è di provare nella
vita di tutti i giorni ad aprire gli
occhi ea vedere che forse la vostra
variabile hicks
per quanto possa essere dolorosa o
difficile da superare
ecco magari questa variabile si possa
trasformare in qualcosa di bello di
positivo forse può essere un po anche
l'eccellenza di cui parlava prima silvia
e come domanda finale vi chiedo
guardateli in basso avete le gambe tutto
a posto sono lì accavallate coi tacchi
poi la testa c'è e quindi mi sorge
spontaneo chiedermi ma cosa aspettate ad
andare a correre siete ancora qui
grazie
ma così mi fate commuovere
grazie prima di lasciarvi leggo anch'io
il mio pensiero
forse vi farà un po ridere quello che
che ho scritto è non tutti i pirati
vengono per nuocere